Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in the chapter of patience
authored by Noah.
We are still in the opening verses of
this chapter. It's very very important
to pay close attention to the verses.
Oftentimes in a book that is geared
towards hadith a person can become a
little bit tunnel visioned and
hyperfocus on the narrations
and overlook the verses. Just in a
book that is primarily geared towards
tia a person can become hyperfocused on
the verses and overlook the narrations
and their relationship. These verses
represent the basis upon which all of
the following narrations are to come. I
want to share a statement of
with you all. mentioned this in his
book. He said that Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala said in he was commenting on a
verse in
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
speaking to the messenger we have sent
down upon you the book
in order that you may judge
between the people and amongst the
people and judge the people based on
what Allah shows you from the book.
Notice the wording based on what Allah
shows you of the book.
Commented on this statement and said,
He said the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
has never made a judgment. Every
judgment he ever made was based on the
verses that he understood from the
Quran. When we look at the Sunnah and
its relationship with the Quran,
we see that the Sunnah has three
three active roles along with the Quran.
Number one, it will say exactly what's
in the Quran. It will reiterate
exactly what's in the Quran.
Number two, it will expound upon and
detail something that is otherwise
generalized and undetailed in the Quran.
So it'll take something that's general
in the Quran and detail it and expound
upon it. And the third is that the
sunnah will have in it something that's
not found in the Quran anywhere.
something that is added something that
is from Allah but it's not found in the
Quran and this is very much for
instance zebra meat is permissible
donkey meat
donkey domesticated donkey meat is haram
where is this in the Quran it's not in
the Quran it's in the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
putting on a
or perfume For a person who is in aam,
this is haram. The scholars have agreed
on this. Is this in the Quran? No, it's
not in the Quran. This is in the Sunnah.
As a matter of fact, this ruling came to
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam in Hajj
when a companion asked him in the exact
same way that the Quran came to him
in salah. Is this in the Quran? No, it's
not in the Quran. These are rulings that
are found in the Sunnah that are not
found in the Quran at all. So we have
number one, the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam says what's in the Quran
exactly. Number two, he details or
expounds upon it or elaborates on what
is something something that's touched
upon in the Quran. Number three, there
is a ruling that is not found in the
Quran at all. There's no fourth. These
are the only three aspects of the Sunnah
with relation with regard to its
relationship with the Quran. Now if we
understand that we understand that the
majority of what the prophet said
is what he understood from the Quran.
The majority
the majority of what he said is what he
understood from the book of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala in his sunnah.
So when you're reading a narration,
often times you are reading
the understanding of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam of what is in the
Quran. And this is why you can find a
root to every narration back in the
Quran in the book of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. They come together. He said,
I have been given the Quran and that
which is it along with it. Meaning
the sunnah it meaning in authority.
Sunnah is the same as the Quran in
authority.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. So when Anoi
mentions verses
all these subsequent narrations are
going to be built and based on these
verses he says
he then mentions the statement of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala verse number 153 of
he says
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commands
saying, "Seek all of you aid in patience
and prayer. Indeed, Allah is with those
who are patient."
So the great merit of patience is that
Allah is with those who are patient.
So Allah tells us that he is with those
who are patient. That's an incredible
merit. And this articulates that it's an
incredible act of worship. But what does
it mean when Allah says seek aid in
patience and prayer? What is meant by
patience and prayer?
Seek aid meaning in those things that
are difficult in your times of
difficulty. When things happen,
something hard happens, something
difficult, a tribulation, a crisis,
an unfortunate im event, a
befallment, what do you do? You seek aid
in being patient through that, but you
seek aid in patience to be patient. What
does that mean?
So some of the scholars because of this
mention that what's meant by patience
here is a
[Silence]
One of the meanings of this is that some
of the companions, some of the scholars
mention that what's mentioned by
patience
is fasting.
Fasting. Why? Because fasting embodies
patience.
It's a proof that I can go without that
which keeps me alive.
I can go without food and drink for a
number of hours. If I can do that and
that is something that I have to have in
order to physically stay alive, then I
can definitely be patient and everything
else. Also,
fasting
is a simulation of the dunya.
What does that mean? It's a simulation
of the dunya. It's a microcosm of our
time on the dunya. Think about it. When
a person begins his fast, he starts with
eating and drinking in the morning
before the sunrise in order to get the
best start. He starts out not eating,
being patient, being patient. Slowly
things get a little bit more difficult,
a little bit more difficult. And they
might encounter extreme difficulty
during the day of fasting. And then
finally, just when the sun sets, the
person eats and drinks. And it's as if
that never happened. It's as if there
there was never any thirst. There was
never any hunger. How many of us are
scarred, suffering from PTSD from
fasting? None of us. It's silly, right?
None of us can remember a time when I
fasted and it was so terrible that I
could never fast again. No, we've had
hard times fasting. But as soon as the
water touches your lips, it's gone. It
was it was an illusion. And that is
a simulation of the dunya. Exactly the
same.
The illusion of the hunger and the
thirst. As soon as the angel of death
comes, immediately it's relieved as if
it never happened.
And this is why we are encouraged to
constantly fast. We'll mention some
other aspects of this verse tomorrow
[Arabic recitation]
or actually Saturday. Fridays we do
merits of the day of J.
Alhamdulillah.